palace est arrivé chez nous la posons
bobines énorme
y'avait d'amour dont il y avait beaucoup
d'amour dans ce film a pris énormément
c'était un team basé là dessus et je ris
en voyant l'extrait parce que quand vous
voyez le livre qui tombe le petit
morceau dessus qu'on a mis dans le dans
le vert andré bonzel le chef op
il a passé mais des semaines à filmer
dans son appartement de trois heures du
matin le plan de com ce serait stupide
plans de coupe de sucre il n'y arrivait
pas c'est là que ça n'avait pas de matos
et tout et tout et après chaque 8 est
libre et de dire je crois que cette fois
je suis arrivé ici
ensuite j'ai eu les randonneurs donc
vous est excellent et puis toujours ce
rôle un petit peu dans les randonneurs
on retrouve dans le boulet ce rôle de
chefaillons un peu quand même hein c'est
que je sais pas pourquoi j'ai un
physique qui prêtent aux petits chefs
qui bonhomme ce cas derrière l'autorité
ouais y'a un truc que je comprends pas
chez vous si vous parlez sans arrêt de
votre physique on vous dénigrent en
visite à 17 ans j'avais déjà une tête de
vieux jeux ça que les copains m'appelait
et de vieux d'avant pas lui dire quand
ils le verront à la télé ils vont rire
ils vont dire oui c'est vrai on
s'aimerait de vieux c'est vrai qu'à 18
ans vous étiez le dernier plus chauds de
la pension oui c'est vrai j'étais plutôt
très tard et j'ai fait un peu chier d
une thèse là dessus